لماذا تمسك الهوت دوج على كعكة عندما
يمكنك تجربة كلب بارد على عصا
مثل مصاصة وينر بنكهة كريمة فقط
أوه ، واو ، لقد أعادوا تزيين
أوسكار ماير وينيرموبيل لأول
مرة للكلب البارد هذا ليس أوسكار هوت
دوج  هو عبارة عن قاعدة جيلاتي أوسكار ماير
متعاونة مع صانعي البوب ​​بار من
الحلويات المجمدة الفاخرة على
عصا ، حتى أن الكلب البارد لديه وهم
الخردل ،
كل من جربه قال نفس
الشيء ولكنه مذاقه حقًا مثل الهوت
دوج ، هل يعجبك هذا
الأمر؟  ليس من اللطيف التحدث بفمك
ممتلئًا خاصةً إذا كان أجمل شيء
يمكنك قوله هو أنه ليس
فظيعًا ، فقد استوحى الكلب البارد من
حملة أوسكار ماير الغبية أو العبقرية التي
تضم عناصر خيالية مثل
مشعل الهوت دوج وكعكة الهوت دوج ،
لكنهم قرروا صنعها.  الكلب البارد
واقع قصير العمر أشعر أن هذا
شيء أملكه في المجمد الخاص بي لفترة
طويلة جدًا
طويلة جدًا أنا
أتابعك صعدنا داخل wienermobile للقيام بجولة سريعة
حيث خرجنا كان هناك ضابط nypd
كنا نخشى أن نعطي
wienermobile تذكرة
بدلاً من ذلك ، فقد أراد أن يجرب طعم كلب بارد
مثل ما
يشبه الدخان المدخن ،
يبدو أن نكهة الجوز المدخنة توفر طعم الهوت دوج
الذي أحبه كلا الضابطين ثم بعد أن
انتهيت من تناوله استمر في
تذوقه.  هوت دوج حتى عندما لم
أعد أتناوله ، فهذا المذاق اللطيف العالق هو
الذي يلتصق بك ، أتمنى أن
يكونوا جني أوسكار ماريو
وينر معظم سي إن إن
نيويورك معي